this is just out of nowhere question but
her is milk
in each country i mean like i've been
told by my friend in california that
we're just talking about baskin robbins
because like we have always
each year they have pokemon
collaboration at baskin robbins right so
you know advice he was complaining that
milk here or ice cream here is too heavy
because of the milk
because we use whole milk in california
they prefer
low fat or grass-fed milk
i didn't notice that that because i
realized now when you told me that the
other day i was like wait
there is never any like semi-skinned or
like no fat milk options you can
order at starbucks but you can buy
low-fat milk though in supermarkets
i feel like i never see it the
supermarket near my house has like skim
milk low-fat milk
uh like high calcium milk stuff like
that but i always wondered i was like
why does milk taste so like
rich yeah i'm like this is weird like
that 100 percent
yes
i like i like the thick stuff because
like in in a straight line
he likes the thick stuff luke i like my
dummy thick milk all right
thick milk because like in australia as
well like we didn't really have a whole
it's like japan like we don't really
have a whole variety of milk
we have obviously we have the full cream
stuff and the low fat stuff
but it's not like america where it's
like would you like one percent two
percent
five percent ten percent it's like just
give me milk
i just want milk no because i
i haven't noticed much of a difference
because i don't i don't normally
i don't know i only have milk with my
coffee yeah so and i don't eat ice cream
too often either i'm not a fan of soft
serve and that seems to be like the most
popular thing i really like soft sauce
it's too milky i like if i want milk
i'll just drink milk
i want ice cream not not ice cream that
tastes like milk well then just don't
get like the vanilla flavored stuff then
get like the weirder
soft serve yeah true like matcha matcha
yeah
that's pretty good but like just normal
macho like black sesame is really good
but vanilla's my favorite flavor of ice
cream so well then stop complaining
just eat your damn sauce okay in japan
as well right uh for some reason baskin
robbins is referred to as 31 wow yeah
what's up with that
how did you who made this it's because
baskin robbins i think might be like
too difficult to pronounce too wrong
because i remember i showed my my
japanese cousin right because she
loves thirty-one ice creams
and i'm just like and when i heard her
first say that i was like 31 what's that
that must be like a japanese brand or
something
right that i don't know i'm like yeah
let's go let's go to 31 ice cream and i
went
and it's a baskin roll yeah and i was
like yeah it's
it's it's just a [ __ ] basket and i'm
just like oh you mean baskin robbins
yeah we have that she's like
baskin what and i'm like it says it
right there
in english we just highlight the
thirty-one yeah
if anything it's harder to see the 31
then
you see the background because because
the katakana is it it just says
31. yeah but i'm like do you clearly not
see
that on either side of the three and the
one it says
baskin robbins and she's like oh my god
i never saw that oh my god it's like 31
is like
five percent of the logo that's crazy
and you're just completely disregarding
the other 95 percent of the lot yeah
it's
i don't know the japanese love to do
that though don't they they love to like
take western brands but completely
change the name of it
just to like fit their like way of
things like i i love how
uh in japan they don't call
mercedes-benz mercedes-benz
right they just call it bins right vince
yeah
you know what i call a mercedes-benz in
japan
[Laughter]
yeah because they can't pronounce
mercedes because when i said that i was
like
they were like what oh what is ben's
like is it bins as an acronym what like
ben's are short for something and i'm
like
yeah it's mercedes-benz and that they
just
their minds were just blown they were
like mercedes where did that come i want
to know the conversation where
mercedes-benz came up that feels like a
code word for like something i would
never say like
if i need to help mercedes-benz no no
because it was in the same conversation
of when i told my cousin that 31 is
called basketball
you're just speed running though yeah
yeah yeah so i had to like make sure
i was like okay what do you call
mercedes-benz because i guess i just saw
a mercedes-benz you call a quarter
pounder with cheese
lately we try to keep the same name like
ben and jerry's kind of like
you guys try to keep i mean not you guys
but you know like anime in general
yeah just for kids but now like we have
the same
title we have the same ops and ending
songs
what do you think about like the other
way how like some
anime series completely changed the name
of the anime to fit like the american
way
right like like what do you think about
how detective conan is called
i understand that conor on the name
conor is just it means
it is isn't it why yeah why why just
detective conan yeah
the character's name that schwarzenecker
played
okay that's fair enough i mean at the
time i think it was coming around those
they were really big
detective conan o'brien i want to see
that now
we have to change the name of a certain
child book
was it from germany uh
called in japan we called him
tantang is a boy who got a
dog with him oh it's tinting oh yes but
tinting sounds
okay yeah
oh yeah yeah
that makes sense